[Musique]
avec vous Hélène frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline à la une de la
presse aujourd'hui on en parlait à
l'instant elle est manifestations de la
colère en Iran après la mort de Marsa
mini cette jeune femme de 22 ans décédée
la semaine dernière lors de son
arrestation par la police des mœurs
c'était à Téhéran la vague de
contestation l'a entendu c'est tant à
présent à une trentaine de villes à
travers le pays mais ce matin pas un mot
de ces manifestations à la une des
quotidiens officielles Iraniens qui
préfèrent revenir on le voit sur la
rencontre hier en marge de l'assemblée
générale le l'ONU entre le président
français Emmanuel Macron et son
homologue iranien Ibrahim une rencontre
qui ramène une lueur d'espoir pour
animer l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
à en croire le iron daily pour prendre
la mesure de ce qui se passe
actuellement en Iran il faut soit se
tourner vers les réseaux sociaux on l'a
évoqué également soit consulter la
presse étrangère notamment Lorient le
jour le quotidien libanais le journal
une colère à visage découvert face à une
répression dont Marsa Amini est devenu
le symbole Marsa Amini dont le père
affirmé dans un entretien à la chaîne
kurde Reader que sa fille arrêtée par la
police des mœurs pour aux motif qu'elle
n'aurait pas été assez couverte aurait
été je le cite d'actu à l'intérieur d'un
véhicule de police alors qu'elle était
détenue ce qui a entraîné sa mort
prématurée au coeur de ces
manifestations Hélène beaucoup de femmes
qui n'ont pas hésité à poster des vidéos
d'elles se coupant les cheveux brûlant
leur voile en France Le Parisien salut
le courage de ces milliers d'iraniennes
qui se trouvent effectivement
actuellement aux avant-postes de la
contestation le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France qui a recueilli depuis Paris les
témoignages de plusieurs manifestantes
dont celui d'une jeune femme de 30 ans
qui dit être descendu dans la rue
pour la troisième fois de sa vie je la
cite j'ai l'impression que nous sommes
toutes otage le hijab le voile islamique
n'est pas la seule atteinte à nos
libertés il y a aussi l'interdiction de
divorcer par exemple nous souffrons tous
ici et les femmes davantage solidarité
aussi du côté de la presse française
avec la destinatrice coco dont le dessin
publié par Libération dénonce la
violence du régime iranien à l'égard des
femmes l'une d'entre elles gîte à terre
recouverte de sang visage bien couvert
comment satisfait un agent de la police
des mœurs iranienne la presse
internationale Hélène qui revient aussi
largement sur l'annonce faite hier de
l'organisation de référendum très
prochainement en Ukraine dans les
régions séparatistes prorus du Dombas
ainsi que celle de Carson et deux aporis
déjà c'est dans le sud de l'Ukraine le
journal russe commerçante précise que
c'est Denis le dirigeant de la
République populaire autoproclamé de
Denis qui aurait adressé hier une lettre
à Vladimir Poutine lui demandant je cite
de bien vouloir étudier la question de
l'intégration de la République populaire
de denisk à la Fédération de Russie un
événement je cite toujours destiné à
réparer une injustice historique de
mascotime quotidien russe indépendant
site lui l'analyse Tatiana tanovaya qui
y voir dans ses référendums un ultimatum
sans équivoque de la Russie à l'Ukraine
et à l'Occident pour s'assurer la
victoire à sur tel Poutine est prêt à
tenir des référendums pour avoir le
droit selon lui d'utiliser des armes
nucléaires afin de défendre le
territoire russe cette annonce faite par
les autorités russes inquiète au plus
haut point en Europe l'ultima folie a
dit Poutine l'ultime la dernière folie
de Poutine le tsar choisi escalade des
référendums ont été convoqués pour
annexer le don-basse Carson les aporez
déjà à Moscou la contre-offensive
ukrainienne est transformée en attaque
contre la Russie dénonce ce matin le
quotidien italien La Stampa en Allemagne
le Frankfurter alguemines
de voir la panique gagner le kremla
visiblement je cite toujours Poutine ne
croit plus être en mesure d'arrêter
militairement la contre-offensive
ukrainienne et si le temps désormais
d'annexer des territoires occupés et de
tracer ainsi une nouvelle frontière pour
la Russie alors l'Occident sera
confronté à des choix difficiles
on ne se quitte pas là-dessus s'il vous
plaît Hélène avant de vous quitter je
vous propose de jeter un fil Pauline à
Libération auquel on desserre ce matin
la palme du jeu de mots et de l'histoire
du jour le monde des échecs on a plein
le pion le dernier épisode en date d'une
affaire qui secoue le monde
habituellement très feutré des échecs
depuis plusieurs semaines ces produits
il y a deux jours pour la deuxième fois
en moins d'un mois le numéro un mondial
Magnus Carlson a jeté l'éponge face à
cette américain en sniemen 19 ans tout
juste ce qui a aussitôt relancé les
rumeurs sur de possibles tricheries de
la part de ce joueur la plus braquet
d'arbres est-ce que je vais y arriver on
la rappelle étant que ce nieiman aurait
utilisé un sextoy connecté je vous
épargne les détails techniques qui
utilisaient avec la complicité d'un
comparti et l'aide d'une intelligence
artificielle extrêmement sophistiquée
aurait sa victoire merci de nous avoir
épargné les détails Hélène et à tout à
l'heure dans Paris